welcome to this video playing miss mang
long miss mangalam from Canada Bishop g5
okay this really crazy line against that
okay nah Bishop age 49 h 6 is what I was
talking about okay let's see here f6 is
some a funny extra tempo not sure what
if it is helpful but at least it's a
non-standard position so let's go for it
okay it's it's a weakening a bit
weakening though that's clear but I have
a center the big center okay let's see
how to how to play Queen B 6 maybe it's
what Quincy to where she's got Quincy to
you don't need to assume that that it's
Han that is really a Miss M you never
know 36 mm no Queen B 6 it's also played
okay to UM to address a possible Bishop
b5 I don't mind the Queen trade real
name c4 takes takes maybeee form
hmm interesting very very complicated
care I play this to prevent light f3 and
maybe allow me to place your form okay
see if i have d for going for be five
before yeah i have a very nice space
advantage but White's position still
feels relatively solid still before I
have III here trying to to irritate him
III he must go back to be one which is
not not very comfortable ok this is this
is simple and good continuation trying
to get the important bishop and the
upcoming before really gives some
substantial pressure on the queenside
here we go
92 I take here on c3 it's not clear what
is move is taking or what her movies I'm
sorry takes Bishop takes you need to
play kini too and this looks really
atrocious maybe check now and now
amongst others that c3 maybe see three
years is this too direct probably I
should strike strike while this as
possible takes Bishop takes just wins
with rook a two
this I didn't he didn't consider even
which does not mean it is necessarily
bad yeah well Bishop e3 Bishop between
now where is this is good as is good how
does he prevents it to even him there's
also night f2 yeah but I thought Bishop
g4 I mean where do you go check to d3
that's night f to check yeah this policy
too I'm just promoting I'm just
promoting okay now Bishop f Michigan
form check
check yeah well as resigned this
ambitious play really paid off yeah f6
is a is a very aggressive way to counter
the smooth this Bishop g5 myth there are
many solid wastes like Knight f6 or h6
everything so this okay this is however
something you must be cautious about
because II form is a quite funky gambit
it's like the Elbe ins with an extra
tempo and this is a tricky and this this
is normally answered by Bishop to H form
and then this is the idea grabbing the
the bishop even like that intending age
for winning this piece leads to very
strange positions but interesting yeah
this is of course super ambitious and
hard to say maybe this is really good I
mean it is a big Center but it can be it
can be weak queen bee three now this one
yeah i don't i don't like that really
this looks like some some nice space
advantage b5 before coming not not clear
to me but this this now this now is very
nice yeah here we we are already in the
range of losing yeah compass on minus
two this is this is not defend
defensible anymore really check check
yeah f6 is a nice way to play against
Bishop g5 if you want a complicated
position quickly it's a it's sometimes
an obligation to have this bigger center
but
it's also providing you with chances to
unbalance quickly thanks for watching